Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan. Wir sitzen hier in der Garderobe der Käs und warten auf unseren großen Auftritt. Der Saal ist voll, aber wir wollen erst einmal ankündigen, was wir als nächstes lesen. Und zwar ist das ein Buch, auf das wir gekommen sind durch die Lektüre des Buchs von Branko Milanovic. Der hat das ja sehr gelobt. Dann habe ich mal nachgeschaut, was ist das überhaupt? The Meritocracy Trap, also die meritokratische Falle von Daniel Markowitz. Und dann sehe ich dort gleich auf dem Cover von drauf A Bold Brave Critique von Michael Sandel, dessen Buch wir ja auch sehr gelobt haben, das uns wirklich die Augen geöffnet hat im Hinblick auf Leistungsgesellschaft und was das eigentlich bedeutet, wenn man von einem Gemeinwesen spricht und warum das das Ende des Gemeinwesens ist. So hat ja Michael Sandel sein Buch genannt, wenn man nur noch meritokratisch denkt. Und wir beschäftigen uns also dann noch einmal mit der meritokratischen Falle und mit der Meritokratie, weil die ja jetzt so vorherrschend geworden ist. Deshalb, weil wir diese Homoplutia haben, von der Milanovic spricht. Das heißt, wir haben Menschen, die nicht einfach nur Vermögen haben und geerbt haben, sondern sie verdienen auch noch gleichzeitig sehr, sehr viel, sind also doppelte Elite und können sich damit auch gut imprägnieren und sagen, ja, aber wir haben doch was geleistet. Warum wollt ihr uns dann den Status madig machen?
Ich bin auch sehr gespannt bei dem letzten Mal, als wir Sendel zum Thema hatten, war ja auch klar, das ist ein Buch, das beim Kanzler auf dem Nachttisch liegt. Ja, auch deswegen haben wir es aufgegriffen und das war also in der bessere Zeit, denn ich könnte mir vorstellen, egal was da drin steht, und wir wissen ja so ungefähr, in welche Richtung uns das Denken erweitert, dass wir es nur noch als Appell formulieren sollen, dass das mal auch bei dem März mit im Klo rumliegen sollte, falls er da mal Zeit hat.
Es wird er aber nicht sein, er wird es nicht gelesen haben, davon können wir eigentlich fest ausgehen. Sag doch mal, was du heute Abend vorhast. Du hast ja eine Stunde vorbereitet, die ein bisschen anders ist als sonst.
Wir machen eine kleine Reise nach Quedlinburg. Keiner weiß, wo das ist, auch egal.
Wien?
Welches Wien? Was ist mit Wien gemeint? Mir geht es auch darum, heute einen neuen Mindset zu pflanzen. Mindset ist ein Wort, das ist bei uns verschrien, aber wir haben heute Spezialpublikum. Wir haben heute Publikum und Publikum. Wir müssen den Podcast heute, also ich meinen Teil, auch ein bisschen instrumentell verstehen. Hier sind Leute, die unser Schicksal in der Hand haben. Meinst du zum Beispiel? Meinst du nicht so? Und denen muss halt in Kürze mal was gesagt werden. Und von daher kommen wir heute nicht ganz um Mindset herum, um uns darüber zu informieren, was ist jetzt zu tun, liebe SPD?
Und nicht nur bezogen auf Frankfurt, das ist dein Beispiel, an dem du es aufmachst. Und Dortmund ist der andere Fall, über den du sprichst. Wir werden aber allgemein da sehen, wie eigentlich sich Kommunalpolitik verändern muss.
Ja, ich möchte, dass die Kommunalpolitik ein neues Mindset hat. Ich will keine weiteren Politiker, die in Berlin auf der Straße stehen und sich freuen, dass sie mal einen Termin beim Kanzler hatten. Sondern ich möchte das genau umgedreht. Ich möchte, dass der Kanzler drum bettelt, dort mal einen Termin zu haben. Und dieses Mindset muss man ausstrahlen. Das muss man haben, das muss man üben. Und wir haben mit drei Jahren hier eine Oberbürgermeisterwahl. Aber im März, wir werden also bilanzt, so heute schon im nächsten Live-Salon 10, ist eine Kommunalwahl in Hessen. Und sag uns mal so, typischerweise reden wir auch nicht über Themen, die uns nur so interessieren, weil sie irgendwie facettenreich interessant oder was auch immer sind, sondern es geht ja immer so ein bisschen um das echte Leben. Und heute ist es das Besondere. Heute geht es einfach, obwohl ich ein Mindset und den großen Exkurs und den Flug ins Weltraum und ein bisschen Fantasia und so, aber heute geht es ums Eingemachte.
Ja, ich bin sehr gespannt, weil du ja auch aufzeigst, wie man sich doch enormen Einfluss erkaufen kann. Man braucht dann nur mal so einen unabhängigen Kandidaten. Und da könnte dann ein Milliardär möglicherweise seine Position gut durchdrücken. Das werden wir uns ansehen. Ich bin gespannt, was es mir nur angedeutet bislang. Ich will mich nochmal mit dem Verhältnis Mensch und Maschine beschäftigen, aber jetzt nicht in dem Sinne, dass ich einen weiteren KI-Podcast dir anbiete. Nein, wir hören erst einmal was Alex Karp, also der Chef von Palantir, über den Menschen und die Menschen und manche Menschen denkt. Dann gehen wir dann zu über, dass wir den Produzenten von Big Brother uns anhören und der sagt ein paar Dinge zu Reality TV.
Deutsch ist Big Brother?
Deutsch ist Big Brother. Ja, in the Mall. Wir werden uns dann einen Clip aus Matrix ansehen. Es könnte ein bisschen abgetroschen sein, denkt man jetzt, ach, jetzt bringt man nochmal einen Clip von Matrix. Das haben wir doch schon alles. Ja, aber wir haben doch eigentlich noch nicht so richtig geklärt, warum liegen eigentlich die Menschen da in diesen Wannen und werden ausgesaugt, da heißt es ja die Energie. Aber welche Energie ist das eigentlich? Das war doch vielleicht immer so eine Frage der Plausibilität. Ist das so sinnvoll, diese Konstruktion? Ich habe jetzt erkannt, doch, die ist sehr sinnvoll. Wir müssen das nur ein bisschen spezifizieren, was eigentlich der menschliche Anteil ist. Wie werden also die Maschinen gefüttert? Und das sehen wir, indem wir uns dann Laber-Podcasts vom Öffentlich-Rechtlichen finanziert sehen, anhören. Wir werden auch zwei, drei Clips noch aus anderen Shows spielen. Wir werden also sehen, wie da das menschliche eingesaugt, abgesaugt wird. Es ist ziemlich gruselig, mitunter sehr vulgär. Ich habe auch einige Clips gestitten gehabt, die ich dann doch wieder jetzt gestrichen habe, weil ich dachte, man kann es hier einfach nicht abspielen. Ich werde jedenfalls versuchen, den ganz großen Bogen dann zu schlagen. Und am Ende kommen wir irgendwo bei der ARD raus.
Ja, okay. Sehr gut. Ich bin gespannt. Wer Interesse hat mit uns, hinter die Paywall zu kommen, die wir den Salon nennen, wo wir also die neue Welt erfinden und uns erzählen, wie es besser sein könnte, geht auf neuezwanziger.de. Dort ist ein goldener Button, der führt direkt zu Steady, unserer präferiert, aber nicht der einzige Weg in den Salon. Da kann man je nachdem, wie, egal, zahlen. Das ist ja im Internet immer noch ein kleines Problem. Creditkarten, EC-Karten, E-Bahn-Nummern, wie auch immer. Paypal, das kann man da alles überspringen. Also dort kann man damit die Paywall überspringen. Dann ist man im Salon, bekommt also jeden Monat den Podcast zugeliefert. Man muss uns nicht fragen, wann er kommt, sondern man wacht morgens auf. Der Podcastscher sagt, der Podcast ist da. Man geht schnell durch die Kapitel, sieht, was einen erwartet, liest den Begleittext, wie auch immer. Das Cover, wenn man Lust hat, kann man das ganze Archiv nochmal durchstöbern. Das geht bei Steady.
Zum Beispiel die Folge zu Michael Sandel könnte man sich nochmal anhören, die denke ich sehr zeitlos ist. Wer schon bei Patreon ist, kann auch darüber buchen oder für die, die es bei Apple bequem haben wollen, auch über Apple kann man den Salon buchen. Und man kann ihn auch bei Steady für ein Jahr verschenken. Wer also noch ein Weihnachtsgeschenk sucht, kann da mal schauen.
Ja, verschenkt eh materielle Güter. Das ist auch gut fürs Klima.
Dieser Podcast wird unterstützt von Procon. Was ist Procon? Procon ist eine Energiegenossenschaft. Wir wissen Genossenschaften. Da schließen sich Bürger zusammen, um ein großes Ziel zu verfolgen und es gemeinsam zu erreichen. Und bei einer Energiegenossenschaft liegt der Zweck meist entweder in der Energieerzeugung oder im Handel von Energie. Es gibt sehr viele Energiegenossenschaften in Deutschland. Und Procon ist eine besonders große Genossenschaft. 40.000 Mitglieder vertreten es Procon in Deutschland, Polen, Finnland und Spanien. Procon setzt auf Wind onshore, auf Speichertechnologien, PV und Biomethan. Und mit dem Kauf von Genossenschaftsanteilen liefern die Mitglieder wichtiges Eigenkapital für den Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien. Bereits mit 50 Euro kann jeder Mitglied werden und somit dann ein bisschen die Energiewende selbst in die Hand nehmen. Man kann natürlich auch Mitgliedschaften verschenken.
Ja, und wenn das nicht mal eine gute Idee ist, an jemanden, der schon alles hat, während man selber nicht mal eine gute Geschenkidee hat, dieses Jahr einfach ein ganzes Windrad verschenken. Ihr habt dann Anteile an Procon, wenn ihr für 50 Euro da einsteigt. Euch gehört genauso viel Stimmrecht über die Windräder wie jedem anderen, die 40.000 Mitglieder, egal wie viel man reinbringt. Die anderen holen nur mehr Rendite raus, aber ihr seid genauso Teil dieser sehr großen Gemeinschaft mit einer sehr guten Idee. Und ihr könnt damit richtig auftrumpfen und pralen. Stellt euch vor, wie ihr unterm Weihnachtsbaum sitzt und der Onkel erfährt, dass er ein Windrad bekommt. Da erspart sich auch jede andere Diskussion über, wer ist hier der Beste. Das ist die Idee, die wir gerne weitertragen. Wir danken Procon sehr dafür, diesen Podcast zu unterstützen. Also auch euch.
Und man hat natürlich als Mitglied dann auch Zugang zu vergünstigtem Strom. Und in den letzten Jahren wurden erfolgsabhängige Dividenden in Höhe von drei bis fünf Prozent ausgezahlt. Es kann sich also lohnen.
Alle Informationen zu Procon in unseren Show Notes. Also greift mal in eure Hosentasche.
Guten Abend hier. Begrüßen alle herzlich hier bei dieser besonderen Weihnachtsshow, die so kaum weihnachtlich wird.
Wieso? Kaum weihnachtlich?
Oder hast du was geplant oder möchtest du singen oder so?
Nein, wir haben hier unseren Weihnachtsbaum. Er brennt schon Lichterloh. Ja. Bisschen metaphorisch natürlich. Wir haben ein paar mehr, ich soll es nicht ansprechen, sagt Wolfgang, Weihnachtsstimmung und so. Aber fühlt ihr euch alle gesund? Es gab wieder mehr Krankmeldungen durch hier Ticketangebote.
Ich denke, du fragst jetzt ja die falschen, weil die die Kranksten sind ja nicht gekommen.
Ist hier jemand krank zur Arbeit gekommen?
Nein. Wir sind natürlich alle kerngesund und freuen sich.
Ich glaube, das Nein geht nicht. Wir sind nicht bei der Arbeit.
Ja, eben. Aber wir schon.
Wir müssen jetzt noch arbeiten. Social Distancing und so, ne?
Zwei Stunden.
Gut.
Ich bin übrigens von einem unserer Hörer gefragt worden, ob ich eigentlich so ein Weihnachtsmarkt Typ sei.
Und?
Und die Reaktion des Publikums genau die richtige. Ich habe nämlich auch gelacht und habe da noch zurückgefragt. Schau doch mal tief in dein Herz. Sag mal Weihnachtsmarkt Typ und denk dabei an mich. Glaubst du, das geht zusammen?
Ich hätte an dich gedacht.
Also ich mag keinen Glühwein. Ich will auch nicht irgendwas fettiges essen, was mir auf den Anzug tropft. Mir ist es auch eigentlich zu kalt draußen. Warum geht man auch nicht rein, wenn es Winter ist? Mir ist das Konzept Weihnachtsmarkt nicht schlüssig.
Ja, aber letztes Jahr hast du eh geglitzert wie ein Weihnachtsbaum.
Das kann man ja auch drin wunderbar tragen. Hast du einen Weihnachtsmarkt Typ?
Ich muss einmal Weihnachtsmarkt. Allein mit dem Karussell. Und ich habe aber, mein Sohn hat gestern hier in der Hauptwache, für Leute, die es kennen, gesungen schon. Und da man den Eltern Bescheid gesagt hat, ich konnte leider nicht hin, hat man 300 Euro eingenommen. Also die Kinder haben eine gute Erfahrung gemacht, den Armen und Gebeutelten zu helfen. Von daher ist Weihnachten ganz gut konnotiert. Und eigentlich haben sie ihren Weihnachtsmarkt damit auch gestern absolut. Glücklicherweise.
Wunderbar.
Darf ich fragen, wer das erste Mal heute bei uns ist? Wer ist zu Gast in Frankfurt für uns? Und jetzt noch mal Gegenprobe. Wer kommt aus Frankfurt?
Es sind doch mehr Gäste hier und es sind gar nicht so viele Lokalpatrioten vielleicht hier. Deswegen musst du jetzt viel erklären.
Ja, genau. Also wir haben für alle, die heute neu hier sind oder den Podcast unser halb kennen, wir teilen uns so ein paar Themen auf. Typischerweise geht es abwechslungsreich zu. Heute habe ich einen Blog, dann hat Wolfgang einen Blog. Wolfgang wird mit uns nachher, können wir kurz an-tease und so ein bisschen Laber-Podcasts.
Das Verhältnis Mensch und Maschine, aber nicht, dass wir jetzt über KI philosophieren, sondern wir beginnen bei Alex Karp, dem Gründer von Palantir und enden bei Laber-Podcast, die das Öffentlich-Rechtliche produziert.
Ja.
Und es gibt einen Zusammenhang.
Genau. Wir wollen euch also sagen, es besteht die Chance, dass ganz am Ende vielleicht noch mal so ein paar humoristische Sachen kommen. 21.45 Uhr vielleicht. Bis dahin ist heute auch ein bisschen Schulunterricht. Aber es sind Leute im Raum anwesend, die ich namentlich nicht nenne und nicht mal in der Funktion. Aber ich will euch trotzdem aufrufen, falls ihr Sachen hört, bei denen ihr denkt, das kann doch nicht wahr sein oder das finde ich gut, zeigt das ruhig. Auch wenn ihr nicht wisst, wer euch hier so zuhört. Aber zeigt das ruhig. Ihr seid Bürger dieses Landes. Ihr habt auch einen Bürgermeister. Wir reden gleich ganz viel über Bürgermeisterkommunalpolitik. Ihr habt auch einen Weihnachtsmarkt. Wir sehen gleich tolle Weihnachtsmärkte. Ihr wollt auch im Grunde in Wien leben, ohne dass ihr das wisst. Ich überzeug euch gleich davon. Zeigt heute ein paar Emotionen, damit es was wird.
Wir lassen das natürlich so geheimnisvoll. Wir wollen nur sagen, es ist jetzt nicht der Bundespräsident im Raum, sondern ein bisschen Lokalpolitik, sagen wir so. An die wir auch besonders jetzt hier das mal adressieren, was wir gleich ausführen.
Der Bundespräsident würde uns ja gar nichts nützen heute. Und das wäre ja der Standardfall.
Genau. Das ist ja das Problem.
Wir sind ja nicht in der Paulskirche.
Wir haben ja ganz häufig diese Diskussionen, die vom Bundespräsidenten für den Bundespräsidenten geführt werden. Und genau das wollen wir nicht. Und wenn es eine Tradition in diesem Podcast gibt, dann war es doch, dass wir immer wieder mal beharrlich darauf hingewiesen haben, dass eigentlich in der Kommunalpolitik das Wichtige geschieht. Weshalb wir jetzt auch den Blick darauf werfen.
Genau. Und ihr seht schon, wir geben uns viel Mühe, um euch zu sagen, Kommunalpolitik ist echt wichtig. Und ich merke selber, wie schwer es eben fällt. Aber wir versuchen es jetzt, euch weise zu machen. Also hier in Frankfurt, ihr wisst es vielleicht, die wichtigste, schönste und bedeutendste Stadt Europas. Reaktionen null. Wir haben einen Oberbürgermeister, der ist so alt wie ich. Das ist ziemlich cool. Denn ihr wisst, wer sonst so regiert in Deutschland. Das sind immer diese Glatzköpfe, die Kai, Wegner, Uwe, Becker oder irgendwie so heißen. Und es ist ja hier in Frankfurt anders. Unser Bürgermeister heißt ja Mike Joseph. Und nächstes Jahr ist Bergfest für ihn. Er ist dann drei Jahre im Amt und dann sind noch drei Jahre im Amt. Und wir haben im März, wir werden also das nächste Mal, wenn wir hier wieder im Salon sind, schon Bilanz ziehen können. Wir machen ja immer so kleine Bilanz-Pressekonferenzen zum Quartal. Und es steht also eine wichtige Wahl an. Und wir müssen das jetzt mal beschreiben, um was es hier eigentlich geht. Denn, vielleicht sage ich es so, Mike Joseph droht leider die krasse Niederlage. Er wird dieses Amt verlieren. Und das wird sich drei Jahre anbahnen. Und danach werden alle sagen, hätte man sehen können, genau, gab es einen anderen Vorschlag? Nein. Braucht man hier vielleicht einen Mindset-Shift oder so? Und ich sage Ja. Und dann sehe ich das schon, guck dir alle Wolfgang an, wie Mindset. Hat Stefan jetzt Mindset gesagt? Ja.
Hast du also den Verstand verloren?
Habe ich, habe ich den Verstand verloren? Genau. Also wir prügeln jetzt den Verstand in die Lokalpolitik wieder ein. Und dieses Szenario, wie Mike Joseph hier verliert, ist dieses, also dieses Jahr schon passiert, nämlich im September in Dortmund. Und wer jemanden, der Dortmund nicht kennt, erkläre ich hier kurz diese Grafik. Ihr seht bunte Balken. Ganz links ist es die SPD. Und das sieht aus wie ein klarer Sieg. Aber ihr seht es auch, das sind noch nicht mal 30 Prozent. Also das ist für so eine erste Wahlrunde. Wir wissen ja dann immer so Stichwahl und so steht dann an. Nicht allzu viel. Danach kommt die Grünen, die CDU, ein bisschen Linke, dann kommt die AfD. Und dann kommt so ein bisschen, ist alles egal, FDP und so. Und dann kommt jemand, da muss man selber so ein bisschen lesen, Kramer, Krämer, Da für Do als diese Partei. Was hat es mit der auf sich? Das versteht ja niemand. So, ich will Folgendes zeigen.
Wie viel Prozent hat diese Da für Do? Hat sie jetzt knapp 15 Prozent?
14,65. Also da hat man schon eine Stadt ordentlich aufgemischt. Dortmund ist ja nicht irgendwo, sondern noch Schlangen der Herzkammer der Sozialdemokratie. Wenn man sich dieses mal als Lager veranschaulicht, dann haben wir hier ein linkes Lager. Da ist völlig klar, wir können die Grünen so ein bisschen reinrechnen, die Linken auf jeden Fall, die SPD auch. Und dem steht ein Lager gegenüber und da ist dann CDU, AfD und dieser Crema drin. Das ist fast eins zu eins. So ein Wahlergebnis, wie es Marjoseph hatte. Man hat so ein Prozent Vorsprung, weil die über 70-Jährigen auch einen Kandidaten haben. Aber eigentlich hat die Stadt sich für Marjoseph entschieden. Und so sah es in Dortmund eigentlich auch aus. Das ist, als wenn man jetzt eine Stichwahl gemacht hätte. Und wir wissen ja alle, vor allem AfDler, die dann in ihr Profil schreiben, hallo, ich heiße Heiner, ich bin 65 Jahre alt, bin hier aufgewachsen, in die Welt gereist, aber der Dortmunder Heimat treu geblieben. Total krass verankert, Ausbildung zum Zeitungsredakteur, Investor Relations Manager bei irgendeiner Wertpapierbank, Sprecher von EON und so weiter. Im Grunde weiß man, mit solchen Leuten macht man es nicht, was ja eigentlich bedeutet. Das sollte doch eine sichere Bank sein, um eine Stichwahl, die so ein Lager hervorruft, zu sagen, da gieße ich eher gegen den AfDler aussprechen und so weiter. Und das ist so ein bisschen schwächelt. Dann gibt es ja ein paar Sonstige, aus diesem 1% Vorsprung müsste man doch irgendwie eine Beziehlinie kriegen. Aber nein.
Also die SPD war klar die stärkste Kraft und die CDU doch recht abgeschlagen. Aber dann gibt es die Stichwahl.
Genau. Und dann gibt es die Stichwahl. Und wir nähern uns jetzt langsam dieser Stichwahl. Den AfDler müssen wir also nicht vorstellen, mit dem will ja keiner was machen. Wie sieht es mit diesem Krämer aus? Martin Krämer. Wir sehen hier so ein, das ist kein Wahlplakat, vielleicht auch ein Wahlplakat. Aber man hatte so gute Ideen in dieser Agenturarbeit, dass man sich gesagt hat, wir machen auf der Webseite vier Bilder, die sich alle drei Sekunden immer durch so Schiebebewegungen, ja. Also das mut ich euch gar nicht zu. Wir zeigen uns die Bilder einzeln. Aber also wir lesen mal vor für die Audiogäste in diesem Podcast. Alter Verwalter, endlich ein Gestalter. Ihr unabhängiger Oberbürgermeisterkandidat für Dortmund.
Spricht mich nicht so an.
15 Prozent. Der hat ein parteiloses Mundwerk.
Der traut sich noch was. Man darf ja sonst nichts mehr sagen, aber der, der, der macht es noch.
Und wieder der Spruch, ganz unabhängig. Ganz wichtig. Das ist die Konstante in dieser Webseite. Hier muss ich auch dreimal lesen. Ich lese euch mal vor. Einfach machen kann alles einfach machen.
Ja, das ist ja auch schon so ein bisschen Linnemann. Einfach mal machen Podcast ist ja sein großes Projekt. Hast du gesehen, er geht jetzt damit auch auf Tournee.
Carsten Linnemann.
Schön, dass ihr euch vor uns entschieden habt. Also Carsten Linnemann ist auch mit seinem Podcast auf Tournee.
Sehr gut.
Hat auch Gäste.
Fährt er mit zum Boot rum?
Nee, er ist an Land, hat auch Gäste. Und zwar Paul Ronsheimer war jetzt da in der Live-Show.
Wer hätte es gedacht? Mist, ich hätte zu Polymarkets gehen müssen.
Ja.
Ich hätte 100 Euro gewonnen. Apropos Carsten Linnemann, ich habe den Clip nicht, aber den Shoke jetzt, wo du es aufgeworfen hast. Carsten Linnemann war gestern beim Deutschlandfunk Interview der Woche. Danach hat Deutschlandfunk, das war der Tag, die Tageszusammenfassung gemacht und eröffnet mit den Worten. Üblicherweise machen wir das nicht, aber wir zitieren jetzt mal unsere Journalistin, die Carsten Linnemann zitierte, befragte. Und dann kam in Sekunde 38 des Podcasts, also die deutsche Tageszusammenfassung für ganz Deutschland. Ja, haben sie sich selber zitiert, wie sie sagen, Herr Linnemann, das stresst mich gerade ein bisschen, dass ich hier gar nichts aus Ihnen rauskriege. Das war der Gesprächsbitt, den sie unbedingt da, also das sind die Zustände. Okay, noch ein Bild von Martin Kremer. Nachdenken gut, vordenken besser. Ihr unabhängiger Oberbürgermeisterkandidat. So, wir haben es also hier mit absoluten spitzen Personal zu tun. Ich will Folgendes anmerken. Dieser Typ hat bei der Dortmunder Oberbürgermeisterwahl fast 0,3 oder so weniger Prozente bekommen als die ganze SPD bei der letzten Kommunalwahl in Hessen. Und wir wissen, der Wind hat sich gedreht, also März droht's.
Und wir müssen noch was zu der Farbe des Plakats sagen. Das ist einmal ein Gelb, das an die FDP gemahnt.
Wer jemanden Erbe antreten will, meint ihr?
Und man hat ein blau, aber nicht ein AfD-blau, sondern das Steuerberater-blau, das auf Visitenkarten normalerweise ist.
Das seriöse Blau, das Gotteslicht, als damals man nicht wusste, wo kriegt man das Gold her, um das zu malen. Da hat man blau gemalt. Ja, also Martin Kremer stellt sich auf seine Webseite vor. Dortmund ist mein Herzensprojekt. Ich will, dass wir Dortmund zu einem Ort machen, an dem auf dem wir alle stolz sein können. Mein Angebot an Sie, da für do.
Also DO. Dortmund. Kennenzeichen.
Steht ihr? Toll. Da für do. Ich will ein Oberbürgermeister sein für alle Dortmunderinnen und Dortmunder. Jeder ist bei mir gleich wichtig. Das ist ein sehr zentraler Satz in seiner Kampagne. Jeder gleich wichtig. Stellt sich die Frage, stimmt das denn? Wenn es stimmt, heißt das, wow, da muss man ganz schön arbeiten. Auf der Webseite gibt es einen Clip von ihm. Also man scrollt so ein Stück weiter unter diesem ganzen Plakate und diesen Spruch. Und dann kommt so ein Clip von ihm. Drei Stück. Ich habe uns mal einen mitgebracht. Er stellt sich vor, also stellt sich uns vor und auch seine Arbeitswut, die er jetzt für die Dortmunder aufbringt. Ich wollte dich eigentlich fragen, wie es dir geht.
Aber wir machen das jetzt ganz lokal, patriotisch. Wie ist es?
Ja, läuft, würde ich sagen. Nee, muss ist so.
Bist du schon im Wahlkampfmodus?
Wir haben noch sechs Monate.
Ich hätte gefragt, bist du betrunken?
Aber so sind auch die Laber-Podcasts gleich.
Ja, das ist hier Buhmann Laber-Podcast.
Er sieht aber auch überhaupt nicht nach Dortmund aus, sondern exakt so sehen ja alle aus, die in Düsseldorf noch mal an der Hotelbar schauen, was noch geht.
Das kann sein. Dortmund ist ja nicht allzu weit weg. Und am Ende will man auch in Düsseldorf mal großen Fußball sehen. Und dann fährt man natürlich auf die Erdbühne in Dortmund.
Wir sind schon im Wahlkampfmodus. Wir haben noch sechs Monate bis zur Kommunalwahl.
Also ich bin noch nicht im Wahlkampfmodus. Der wird anders aussehen. Das ist ganz, ganz klar. Und das ist auch gut, dass so ein Wahlkampf, so eine heiße Wahlkampfphase nicht über zig Monate geht. Nein, ich bin ja ein parteiloser Kandidat. Und als parteiloser Kandidat fehlen dir natürlich, ja es fehlt hier so ein Parteibackground für viele organisatorische Dinge. Und das muss ich natürlich alles aufbauen. Das tue ich. Aber ich habe natürlich auch schon viele Themen, an denen ich arbeite. Logischerweise brauche ich natürlich auch einen Unterstützerkreis, wo ich schon sehr viel positives Feedback habe. Also ich sag mal wir laufen an und ich muss natürlich eins machen. Und damit werden wir jetzt auch zügig beginnen. Dadurch, dass ich keine Partei als Marke habe, sondern sozusagen als Person für das Amt des Oberbürgermeisters von Dortmund kandidiere, habe ich natürlich nicht die Bekanntheit in die ganze Stadtgesellschaft hinein. Und die müssen wir natürlich bis zum Wahlkampf aufbauen, damit die Leute auch das Interesse an uns und unseren Themen haben.
Der arme Arme meint, wer kennt das nicht? Man hat ja gar keine Partei. Man muss das alles selber machen. Und das ist voll die Arbeit. Aber für die Dortmunder macht man es halt gerne. Denkt man sich Versprüche aus für die Webseite, tingelt so ein bisschen rum, um dann zurückgelehnt Holzvertäfeld da rum zu hängen und zu sagen, ja, ich hänge mich hier voll rein. Das ist im Grunde, wie man sich vorstellt, dass, also ich kenne mich wenig aus im Fußball, aber ich weiß, die Dortmunder müssen nicht gewinnen, aber sie müssen zeigen, dass sie Gras gefressen haben. Wenn du richtig geackert hast, dann kannst du auch auf Platz drei was werden. Also das ist hier. So, wir haben in Frankfurt sehr gute Erfahrungen mit dritten Kandidaten, die unabhängig antreten. Wir hören jetzt mal beispielhaft Peter Wirt, unseren Bahnbabo. Für alle, die Frankfurt nicht kennen.
Du musst jetzt sagen, wer ist der Bahnbabo?
Ja, ich sage es mal nicht, wer das ist, sondern ihr versucht jetzt Unterschiede zwischen Martin Kremer in Dortmund, der in Frankfurt trittplatziert, und Peter Wirt in Frankfurt trittplatziert zu sehen. Die FAZ stellt ihn uns vor.
Blenden, weiße Zähne, dicke Oberarme und Sonnenbrille, das sind die Erkennungszeichen von Peter Wirt alias Bahnbabo. Wenn er in der Straßenbahn sein körperliches Können zeigt, dann ist das Sport am Arbeitsplatz. Denn er ist Straßenbahnfahrer bei der VGF, der Verkehrsgesellschaft Frankfurt.
Ich dehne jeden Tag und versuche, meinen Körper flexibel zu halten. Mein Motto ist, bist du flexibel, wie der Baum im Wind, kein Lebenssturm dich hier bezwingt. Und das stimmt.
Bürgermeister von Frankfurt will er werden, erzählt er nach der Arbeit.
Punkte von mir werden in jedem Fall der Nahverkehr sein, da bin ich zuhause. Es wird die Wohnungssituation in dieser Stadt sein, es wird die Jugend sein. Wir brauchen mehr Betreuung dieser Jugend. Warum hat das Jugendhaus am Wochenende zu? Ich muss auch arbeiten am Wochenende. Wir brauchen mehr Jugendbetreuer. Die müssen auch am Samstag und am Sonntag für diese jungen Leute da sein. Wir müssen sie von der Straße holen. Wir müssen ihnen Angebote machen. Das passiert viel zu wenig. Also hier Brücken bauen.
Doch der Einzug ins Rathaus setzt einen erfolgreichen Wahlkampf voraus.
So, 10 Prozent. Applaus für den Bahnbarboa.
Ein Mann, der aussieht wie Arnold Schwarzenegger, aber Spagat kann wie die Kessler Zwillinge. Also das ist ja unglaublich.
Also Frankfurt ist eine coole Stadt. Ja, wir sehen das schon. Das sind unsere Plätzierten. Aber leider reden wir ja über Dortmund und über die Zukunft von Frankfurt.